sie sind laut wer eine globale bedrohung
impfgegner nicht wieder raus in zeiten
der korona pandemie erhalten sie
auftrieb ihre angst nicht das
gefährliche virus sondern eine
impfpflicht
also ich bin nicht dafür dass ich wenn
ich diese impfung keinen wind wehen
dabei gibt es in deutschland gar keine
impfpflicht es sei denn kinder besuchen
eine kita oder schule dann müssen die
eltern nachweisen dass ihre kinder gegen
masern geimpft sind dagegen mobilisieren
die impfgegner
wir begeben uns mitten unter sie mit
falschem namen und erfundenem kind und
finden so heraus wie ärzte helfen die
impf nachweispflicht zu umgehen und
damit uns alle gefährden
[Musik]
anfang mai auf einer demo von
impfgegnern in stuttgart viele
teilnehmer innen waren vor einer
impfpflicht gegen korona obwohl es noch
nicht mal einen impfstoff gibt hätten
wären wir schon lange alle droht manche
demonstrantinnen haben schlicht angst um
ihre gesundheit
andere glauben an verschwörungstheorien
in impfgegner gruppen zum beispiel auf
facebook vermischt sich häufig beides
angst und desinformation
viele eltern sind dadurch verunsichert
und zweifeln an dem nutzen von impfungen
der wissenschaftlich gut belegt ist
jakob maske ist kinderarzt in berlin er
weiß impfstoff schützt zuverlässig
dennoch begegnen ihm viele eltern mit
bedenken
die zahl der verunsicherten eltern nimmt
deutlich zu
durch eben die öffentlichen oder auch
vor einigen sozialen medien
wir sehen dass viele eltern zweifeln auf
impfungen auch gut sind aber durch
unsere aufklärung erreichen wir
eigentlich dass wir diese skeptischen
eltern auch dazu bringen ihre kinder so
zu impfen wie es wirklich gut für sie
ist
es gibt in deutschland keine impfpflicht
aber seit dem ersten märz brauchen
kinder für den kita und schulbesuch ein
nachweis über eine masernimpfung
ausgestellt wird diese meist von kinder
ärzten wie jakob maske der grund für die
nachweispflicht die virusinfektion ist
extrem ansteckend und kann zu
schwerwiegenden schäden führen
in einem von 1000 fällen endet sie
tödlich
weltweit starben 2018 140.000 menschen
an masern
wirklich helfen kann nur eine impfung
allergische reaktionen hingegen sind
nachweislich extrem selten
bei einer millionen geimpften treten sie
nur in ein bis vier fällen auf
trotz der sehr eindeutigen faktenlage
sprechen impfgegner gern von im wahnsinn
und panikmache
die weltgesundheitsorganisation erklärte
sie bereits 2009 10 zur globalen
bedrohung denn um das virus auszurotten
müssen möglichst viele menschen geimpft
seien ungeimpfte sind eine bedrohung
auch für ihre mitmenschen
trotzdem gibt es sogar ärzte die vor dem
impfen waren und nicht vor dem maß an
die ärztin meint impfschäden würden
vertuscht eine verschwörungstheorie die
auf dieser impfgegner demo 2009 10 gut
ankommt und das ist ein wirklich unsere
gesundheit
und wenn man immer geredet wird man
herben immunität oder von herrn schutz
und ich sehe aber gehen wenn man die
sieben immer kein kampf wird dann möchte
ich nicht teil dieser herne seien
wirklich nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
eine impf gegnerin mit eigene arztpraxis
die medizinerin redet gerne auf anti
impf demos ihre auftritte verbreiten
sich auch auf youtube hier wie auch an
anderen orten im netz gibt es ärzte die
sich offen gegen das impfen aussprechen
zum beispiel impfen nützt nichts impfen
schützt nicht impfen schadet in
geschlossenen facebook gruppen und
impfkritischen foren tipps wie eltern
die impfpflicht am besten umgehen können
wir geben uns selbst als kritiker aus
immer wieder fällt das stichwort imf
unfähigkeit eine arztpraxis gibt online
anleitung inklusive mustertexten wie man
am besten an eine impf unfähigkeit
bescheinigung kommt und dann stoßen wir
auf einen arzt der per mail direkt eine
impf unfähigkeit bescheinigung anbietet
gegen geld bitte senden sie uns einen
frankierten rückumschlag mögliche
gesundheitlich relevante probleme in der
familie vergütung der bescheinigung 10
euro bitte in silberpapier einwickeln
und wir sehen ihn schnellstmöglich eine
impf unfähigkeit bescheinigung wolfgang
schick
eigentlich ist die bescheinigung für
sehr seltene fälle gedacht zum beispiel
für schwerkranke kinder mit
immunschwächen die wirklich nicht
geimpft werden dürfen
wir machen die probe und schreiben dem
arzt unter falschem namen erfinden ein
kind namens jacob und bitten um die
bescheinigung die zehn euro packen wir
in alu papiere wie von dr schiller beten
wir warten ob unser erfundenes kind
tatsächlich eine impf bescheinigung
bekommt und fragen derweil den
kinderarzt jakob maske wie er das
angebot des kollegen findet
[Musik]
absolut schockiert dass so was ein arzt
durchführt absolut schockierend für mich
der kinderarzt der per mail die
bescheinigung anbietet macht aus seiner
einstellung keinen hehl
auf einem sogenannten informations
kongress im april lässt sich dr scheel
als unerschrockener kämpfer gegen die
impfpflicht feiern heute freue ich mich
ganz besonders auf den kinder- und
jugendarzt dr wolfgang schoen der
erklärt online wir eltern hilft die
masernimpfung zu umgehen
es kann sie niemand niemand nach der
papst das gerichtlich zwingen
eine impfpflicht gibt es nicht nun aber
es gibt im nachweislich zu können und
hält mir schon dass sie nachweisen dass
ihr kind nicht für die nachweis reicht
angeblich die angabe einer familiären
vorerkrankungen
eine woche später bekommen wir post von
dr die impf unfähigkeit bescheinigung
für jakob für ein kind das es gar nicht
gibt
der kinderarzt hat trotzdem einer test
geschickt
warum macht er das wir bitten um ein
interview schicken ihm unsere fragen
keine antwort auch am telefon kann
durchkommen wir besuchen ihn in seiner
praxis auch hier kein interview
stattdessen verweist er hinterher per
mail auf die vielen eltern die sich an
ihn wenden um so dem impfzwang zu
entgehen
warum er kindern ein ärztliches attest
aus stellt die er gar nicht kennt
erklärte er im juli 2020 auf nachfrage
so die eltern neben den wiesen aufwand
auf sich um wegstrecken zu uns über
sechs sieben acht stunden zu bewältigen
ist das nicht illegal
die bundesärztekammer sieht dr scheels
verhalten jedenfalls kritisch er hat das
kind nie gesehen hat sich also nie davon
überzeugt dass tatsächlich eine
anerkannte gegenanzeige für eine
masernimpfung vorliegt und dann hätte er
ein unrichtiges zeugnis ausgestellt und
das müsste staatsanwaltlich geprüft
werden der kassenärztlichen vereinigung
ist dr scheel schon länger als
impfgegner aufgefallen
im februar demonstrieren vor dem gebäude
eltern dafür dass er seine zulassung als
kassenarzt behalten darf dass der arzt
impfen fähigkeit bescheinigung ausstellt
ohne patienten untersucht zu haben war
hier nicht bekannt wenn der arzt dass in
einzelfällen es gibt sicher medizinisch
begründbare einzelfällen das tut dort
die kinderärzte das tun dann ist es in
ordnung wenn es aber am fließband
ausgestellt wird gar noch ohne
untersuchungen oder auch ohne
körperkontakt dann ist es sicher
schwierig und würde auch verfolgt werden
um das maß an schutz gesetz zu umgehen
schrecken impfgegner vorstrafe
handlungen nicht zurück sie geben in
ihren foren tipps wo man einen blanko
impfpass erhält wie probieren es aus
für nur drei euro fünfzig bestellen wir
einen leeren impfpass auch ärzte stempel
gibt es online einfach zu kaufen
selbstverständlich kann man
käuflich erwerben um sie es auch selber
ausfüllen das ist allerdings eine
urkundenfälschung und kann
strafrechtlich verfolgt werden
besonders fatal sind solche methoden für
menschen wie sie gabi schellbach ist
kindergärtnerin in kehl baden
württemberg 117 kinder betreuen sie in
der städtischen kindertagesstätte
wer von ihnen gegen masern geimpft ist
und wer nicht sollen die erzieher innen
kontrollieren
doch die impfpässe sind nicht immer
vollständig ausgefüllt nachgetragen wo
wir nicht wissen wer dieses gemacht habe
wie also sollen kindergärten und schulen
überprüfen ob die impf nachweise echt
sind oder nicht nachfrage beim
bundesgesundheitsministerium
dazu gibt es keine antwort die
verantwortung lastet allein auf ihren
schultern und auch die sorge dass die
kleinsten die noch zu jung sind für die
impfung durch die masern gefährdet
werden
deswegen möchte sich gabi schellbach
wenigstens auf bescheinigung verlassen
können die von ärzten ausgestellt sind
ich vertraue den ärzten und dann erwarte
ich auch dass die ehrlich sind und auch
ehrliche bescheinigungen ausstellen
solange sich einige ärzte daran nicht
halten bleibt das risiko dass kinder der
gefährlichen masern infektion schutzlos
ausgeliefert sind
was denkt ihr sollte der staat auf
impfungen bestehen und nachweise
einfordern
schreibt es in die kommentare